a lot of different ways anchoring that
defense
Distributing it offense going to the
glass and scoring has pulled the depot
oh man grabs that left knee anytime
given his injury history you see all the
depot go to the ground what that young
man is
gone through and come back from it just
everybody holding their breath
foul is on Middleton he just fouled out
I'll check that Portis excuse me just
fouled out
we saw Cody Zeller that was a teammate
of all the Depots at Indiana
and immediately
Victor grab that left leg
oh boy back in a moment
oh you're just devastated for Victor
Oladipo
being helped off
grabbed his left knee immediately when
he went to the ground
played in just eight games last year
because of injury only 33 games two
years ago with three different teams
only 19 games played in 2020 because of
injury
he knew it right away to to see on the
plant there with the left leg he grabs
the left knee and then as Caleb Martin
comes over his teammate Victor doesn't
say anything and then just says no
he knew right away something was wrong
and
entire building right now is silent and
so many Miami Heat fans have been a part
of this recovery Journey for Victor
Oladipo brought in rehabbed here people
are so familiar with this story when he
was able to really start having an
impact just the basketball Community
here and especially in Miami but just in
general Victor is one of those guys that
you root for the emotion that you're
seeing on the Miami Heat bench is
because
not because of the injury but because of
the person we see injuries happen and it
sucks but ultimately as a person Victor
is one of those guys that you root for
and you know his journey and what he has
been through so to to have that happen
here in the postseason game and now we
don't want to we don't want to make it
seem like there is something but there
isn't definitely an energy in here and
the way he was talking and what we saw
Victor doing on the floor makes you feel
like it's something more than just
casual and you were just talking about
how good he's been in the series and how
much they need him with with Tyler hero
out so he was one of the players when I
was talking about is like there's some
hungry players out there on the Miami
Heat uh bench and so to see that that is
so tough for him to get that opportunity
and and really to maximize like oh wait
I get an opportunity to play 25 minutes
it's about how well I perform in the
energy I bring his defense has been
outstanding tonight and just a tough way
to see this game potentially in former
number two pick in the draft there there
were some people early on in his career
in Orlando thought that he wasn't that
type of player he gets Oklahoma City
ends up winning most improved player we
see that All-Star Talent on full display
and then the injuries obviously became a
huge story